[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
comme chaque semaine nous parlons des
sujets qui font l'actualité
lutter contre la solitude des anciens
renforcer les liens entre les
générations depuis plusieurs années de
nouveaux dispositifs de vie se met en
place certains pensent et par des
associations et des communes l'habitat
intergénérationnel est il devenu un
nouveau mode de vie c'est le sujet dont
on parle ce soir que nos invités
bertrand lyon bourg soir bonjour vous
êtes le maire de magny les hameaux
maryse bresson bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
professeur de sociologie monde du
laboratoire 30 ans à l'université
versailles saint quentin et bérangère
péno bonsoir bonsoir mais l'ami vous
êtes chargé de mission à
ensemble2générations qui notamment met
en lien un ces différentes générations
alors parmi les différentes les
différences les différents habitats part
d'un possible intergénérationnelle il y
à la colocation je propose de commenc se
situe société en partant à marly-le-roi
on va à la rencontre de monique et
giulia elles nous ont accueilli le temps
d'un reportage pour nous partager les
raisons de ce choix et leur quotidien
les images sont signés bixente mais rien
santisteva vous l'hégémonique komova sur
6 à
18 heures giulia vient de terminer ses
cours en visio l'étudiante en master à
la sorbonne partageant thé avec monique
l'été c'est aussi comment dire c'est un
rituel en tant qu elle prenne pour
parler de leur journée elles ne sont pas
grands mères et petite-fille mes
colocataires depuis trois ans arrivé en
france en 2018 julia ne veut pas se
retrouver seul sans nécessairement
partager une colocation avec des jeunes
de son âge elle se tourner vers
l'association ensemble2générations qui
fait le lien entre seniors et jeunes on
peut partager d'autres activités comme
paris aller au cinéma au théâtre
surtout avant de coheed n'a pas
énormément on peut regarder la télé
ensemble parfois je fais la cuisine ou
alors j'ai accompagné mon nico marché le
dimanche
on bavarde voilà on fait parfois
on regarde des émissions où
je les fais lire ce que j'ai des devoirs
que j'ai fait les dossiers que j'ai
écrit pour master au décès de son époux
money boké ne veut pas être seule chez
elle mais ne souhaite pas quitter son
domicile ses enfants découvrent
l'association en moyenne les colocations
dure deux ans c'est un accompagnement je
peux pas dire les choses se font même
les choses imprévues ben on les prend
pied en s'en arrange mais on n'est pas
maniaque ni sur l'heure du déjeuner ni
digne et si je voulais envie de
téléphoner longtemps ses parents pareil
moi je suis dit aussi ben moi je peux
pas inventer leurs noms mais les choses
elles se sont naturellement et c'est ça
que je trouve vraiment formidable je
vous lis à devrait rester chez monique
le temps de terminer son master
l'étudiante est la sixième personne
accueillie par monique qui gardent
contact avec ses colocataires même après
leur départ de la maison comme un lien
familial
bérengère pedneault vous êtes
l'association qui a mis giolias et
monique en relation pourquoi vous être
lancée sur ce lien intergénérationnel
oui
ensemble2générations est né d'un constat
ensuite à la canicule de 2003 qui a
effectivement montré que de nombreuses
personnes âgées étaient isolés et loin
de leurs familles et puis un autre
constat en parallèle c'est la difficulté
des étudiants à se loger donc tu n 2
enfin teigneux qui a créé cette
association en 2006 a décidé de recréer
des liens entre les générations de faire
des prix même entre les cultures et a
donc créé ensemble de génération ces
binômes sont durs à faire alors c'est
tout un travail de terrain puisque on
rencontre chaque personnage et à son
domicile pour connaître ses attentes ses
besoins connaître son cadre de vie pour
savoir aussi son caractère si elle
préfère voilà être plutôt tranquille ou
au contraire elle aime beaucoup le
partage tous ces points là sont
importants et puis chaque étudiant
rempli un dossier à l'issue de ce
dossier s'il est sélectionné on organise
un entretien personnalisé avec le jeune
pour là aussi connaître ses motivations
son projet et puis son caractère puisque
l'idée c'est vraiment de pouvoir réussir
un match shing je vais employer ce mot
anglais mais ce match parfait entre les
personnes pour que la cohabitation se
passe bien et puis même va se renouvelle
au fil du temps un petit peu comme à la
giulia et monique qui entament leur
troisième année mais c'est vraiment ce
travail de terrain de d'aller à la
rencontre à la fois de nos seniors et de
nos jeunes pour pouvoir les mettre en
relation et puis après il ya tout
l'accompagnement avec l'association
assure un suivi pour pour permettre que
la cohabitation se passe bien s'il ya
des petites choses à régler on est là
pour le faire et est également il ya
bien sûr un contrat de cohabitation
intergénérationnelle qui établit avec la
loi et lent donc les seniors comme les
étudiants soit encadrée juridiquement
maryse bresson cette solitude du senior
elle a toujours existé elle s'est
renforcée avec notre société sans parler
du coc vide qui a peut-être encore plus
éloigné les générations
alors non la solitude du senior on peut
pas dire qu'elle est toujours existé en
tout cas qui on situe dans l'histoire
longue il ya quand même eu des familles
justement qui qui étaient des familles
alors des familles touchent des familles
en tout cas qui vivait à plusieurs
générations sous le même toit c'est vrai
que depuis l'industrialisation donc ses
anciens il ya une tendance à ce que les
familles soient des familles dont
uniquement par an et enfin en bas âge de
plus en plus pour une mobilité et donc
voilà donc c'est pas une question
nouvelle cela dit je crois que la dalle
est qu'à citer bérengère les noces de
2003 pour revenir à des dates plus
récente est quand même importante parce
que c'est là qu'a eu une vraie prise de
conscience de sortir de la problématique
de l'isolément des personnes âgées donc
sans doute voilà que c'est quelque chose
qui s'est structurée mais
progressivement pour nos sociétés est
pas
nécessaire mais qui arrive et qui a paru
de manière vraiment très visible avec
toutes les conséquences négatives donc
de la canicule et la découverte que des
personnes search et elle est vraiment
beaucoup frappé le monde de la société
civile comme on dit et aussi les
pouvoirs publics puisque pour beaucoup
dans des familles le lien avec les
parents grands parents voire
arrière-grands-parents pour ceux qui ont
des générations parfois courtes c'est
très important comment on peut expliquer
qu'un lien entre un senior et un jeune
qui ne connaît pas qu'il n'a pas vu
grandir maryse bresson ça reste
important
alors il ya deux choses différentes
qu'il faut bien distinguer un ex pense
que effectivement on est au croisement
de plusieurs choses d'une part il ya le
vieillissement il ya le fait de vouloir
vivre à domicile aussi par en
institution et c'est pour les personnes
âgées donc ça c'est une chose et d'autre
part il ya le fait que la famille en
tout cas les enfants les petits enfants
parce que c'est le fonctionnement de
notre société sont mobiles autonomes ils
ne sont pas là après ce qui se passe
donc ça croiser un deuxième de la
deuxième problème donc isolement des
personnes âgées qui est celui d'autres
familles précaires de jeunes notamment
d'étudiants mais pas seulement qui se
retrouve avec un vrai problème d'accès
au logement et du coup on a dû par des
personnes âgées qui sont dans des
logements elle peut fondre un peu grand
pour elle parce que la situation a
changé parce que voilà elles sont plus
qu'à deux voire une personne seule et
d'autre part des personnes qui ont
vraiment un gros problème d'accès au
logement alors cela dit pour tes pas de
la sociologie mais pour raconter une
anecdote dès les années 90 j'avais une
amie qui était déjà dans cette situation
donc c'est pas quelque chose qui on
découvre totalement je crois que ce qui
est nouveau c'est que ça s'organise mais
qui était étudiante et qui effectivement
via notamment une communauté donc parce
qu'elle était d'origine chinoise donc
avait trouvé une personne âgée qui
l'avait accueilli très bon marché
qu'elles rendaient du service donc c'est
quelque chose qui existait déjà ce qui
est peut-être nombreux c'est la manière
dont ça se systématiser ça s'organise
dans un contexte de besoins réciproques
-qui qui sont très bas et je disais au
début il ya des associations mais il ya
aussi des communes maintenant qu'ils
s'intéressent à ce projet bertrand aux
lions à magny les hameaux c'est même un
plan qui qui mûrit depuis plusieurs
années c'est juste ça pourrait devenir
presque concret c'est ça
c'est un sujet sur lequel on travaille
en effet depuis une dizaine d'années
puisqu'on avait reçu une étude grâce à
l'observatoire à l'époque de saint
quentin en yvelines qui nous montrait la
progression du vieillissement de la
population sur une commune qui est de
base très jeune comme l'ensemble de la
construction de saint quentin en
yvelines et notre responsabilité en tant
que co buhl et de pouvoir aménager notre
ville à la fois pour permettre à tous
les âges de continuer d'habiter sur la
commune
dans des logements qui soit adaptée
finalement différents âges mais aussi
elle de créer les conditions pour éviter
lisent le cas pour lutter au maximum
finalement pour permettre un maximum de
rencontres et d'inclusion de tous les
âges aussi dans la bible donc dans ce
cadre là où on avait entamé d'abord des
choses plutôt classique
de deux logements ou entre le groupement
d'habitat avec de l'intergénérationnel à
l'intérieur avec quelques animations
mais a créé direct ou pour les habitants
avec du locatif social accession aidée à
la propriété
on envoie un moment donné les limites
puisque le sa demande ce qui va passer
des plus grands habitat avec plus d'une
cinquantaine de logements
finalement la période de confinement a
beaucoup aidé à rapprocher les
différentes fédérations à l'intérieur
puisqu'il ce simulateur visière dinars
on semble à à l'échangé des lectures à
échanger des courses soucier des
différents services maintenant on va
aller plus loin en créant je vais
prendre l'exemple d'une grosse maison de
sa vie dans laquelle
pourront habiter et cohabiter et et
faire ensemble leur habitat destinés à
des familles monoparentales
des jeunes et qui sont des cohabitations
et qui ne fane leur autonomie
travailleurs ou étudiants et et puis des
personnes en situation d'handicap à
moins de 300 mètres de l'ensemble des
services parce que c'est important
d'avoir cette proximité et avec un café
solidaire permettent aussi de créer de
l'animation pour l'ensemble du quartier
et de permettre les rencontres et puis
éventuellement une micro crèche qui
permettent aussi il ya plus de mélange
entre générations c'est un projet que
nous on est en train de travailler
aujourd'hui avec une association qui
s'appelle maison mag l'ajustement des
réunions préparatoires ont déjà élu s
vous êtes déjà des retours du public
s'est intéressé et justement pour ceux
qui seraient intéressés ce sont des
seniors des jeunes familles des
étudiants
l'association a mené plusieurs
permanences pendant le mois de janvier
ce qui permet de voir justement
l'attrait de la population directement
de mesnil de magny les hameaux sur ce
dossier
il ya eu au moins une vingtaine de
personnes qui sont venues avec et qui
ont marqué un véritable intérêt à la
fois des seniors
à la fois des familles qui ont soit chez
elle soit qu'ils connaissent autour
d'elle des personnes qui peuvent être en
situation de handicap ou de fragilité
et les souhaits sont d'une part à la
fois d'un intérêt pour y habiter de nous
pour pouvoir construire lavit et le
projet collectif mais aussi des
personnes et notamment des seniors qui
sont intéressés pour pouvoir participer
en tant que bénévole à l'animation de
l'ensemble de l'espace la création du
jardin à des petits travaux a dit
bricolage mais maryse bresson on
l'entend
ça dépasse finalement la simple vie
quotidienne ça va être des gens qui
seront parfois que de passage la journée
mais ça recréer une une société aussi
alors ça c'est une question importante
ne se sont pas des liens familiaux
puisque les biens familiaux voilà
correspondent aussi à des liens donc de
filiation de parenté d'or éventuellement
matrimoniaux mais ce sont quand même des
liens forts des liens de proximité
qui se nouent et donc séance a
effectivement que ça ça donne à penser
en tout cas c'est pas seulement des
liens d'un sociabilité numérique des
liens intenses là ce sont des liens
réels concret c'est aussi de l'entrée
dans l'intimité des personnes et donc
effectivement il ya un je forme autour
de cette recréation de nouveaux liens de
proximité avec des personnes qui ne sont
pas immédiatement j'allais dire proche
mais qu'ils le deviennent via ces
dispositifs nouveaux qui se systématise
taux qui se crée bérengère friends vous
souhaitez réagir oui oui c'était réagir
parce que c'est vrai que je suis
ensemble2générations c'est ce qu'on voit
effectivement
finalement devancé dans ces binômes qui
sont créées c'est que parfois on a des
jeunes qui arrivent qui peuvent être un
petit peu en pas forcément rupture
familiale mais parfois avec voilà leurs
propres parents c'est un petit peu
difficile ils ont pas toujours connu
leurs grands-parents et en fait de venir
habiter chez une personne âgée et bien
il recrée ce lien qui parfois leur
manque et qui est nécessaire pour
pouvoir se construire et ce lien est
vraiment important ils se sentent voilà
auprès de la personne âgée donc comme
ici à la fois eu les aides mais ils sont
aussi très idée par ces seniors qui les
amène à réfléchir sur des tas de sujets
et de voir les choses un petit peu
autrement et parfois ça apaise aussi les
relations donc c'est très bénéfique et
puis ces mêmes seniors se sont très
utiles aussi ils ont ce sentiment
d'utilité de dire voilà aujourd'hui dans
la société je n'emporte tout ma place et
j'apporte quelque chose à ce jeune et ça
c'est vraiment très important je pense
que pour dans le développement du
maintien à domicile ça fait partie des
choses qu'il faut qu'il faut tout à fait
au courage et mais bien troyon me
souhaité réagir en plus cela dans le
reportage madame bloqué dit qu'elle a
fait ce choix après la disparition de
son mari
c'est un choc très violent les enfants
sont partis déjà depuis plusieurs années
il ya aussi cette volonté de redonner la
place aux seniors qui l'a dans la
société
moi je je je veux saluer parce que les
actions des associations comme comme
celle de bérangère pénaux parce que la
question du réseau est fondamental dans
dans ce cadre là je sais pas un simple
aménagement qui va changer les choses
c'est pas une création de structures
enduire les unes à côté des autres qui
vont changer les choses mais c'est
justement cette inclusion et le fait de
donner confiance finalement à leur place
dans la société pour les seniors réussi
pour les plus jeunes et on sait qu'il ya
d'expérience forcément des deux côtés
les inquiétudes du côté des jeunes pour
aller chez un senior on n'a pas tous
forcément les mêmes horaires par exemple
des choses comme ça et puis pour les
seniors d'accueillir quelqu'un qui ne
connaissent pas et notamment un jeune
chez eux sa demande
voilà certaines explications un
accompagnement qui qui est fait par par
ces réseaux tron connaissent à la fois
les jeunes mais à la fois les seniors
pour pouvoir justement vous parliez de
les faire match et quelque sorte que les
relations humaines et sans ce travail
soins d'accompagnements ça ne pourrait
pas forcément fonctionner et surtout on
pourrait avoir un certain nombre
d'échecs qui prendrait le dessus par
rapport au reste et ça c'est le réseau
bénévole humain est qui et qui est
majeure dans ce cadre là et qui ne
pourra remplacer par rien d'autre et
surtout pas du commerce ça c'est
exactement c'est vraiment vraiment
simple
oui en fait ce que je voulais compliqué
mais bertrand a commencé à le dire bon
voilà ça apporte effectivement des
choses et donc on a parlé des aspects
positifs fin évidemment par rapport donc
des avantages que cela permet de
diminuer les frais oublier service de
lutte y compris d'isolement mais aussi
des inconvénients il ya aussi des
limites bien sûr et notamment c'est tout
moi un mouvement dans une trajectoire
notamment pour les jeunes d'ailleurs
qu'ils sont ou pour les personnes qui
sont accueillis elles ont plus héberger
que loger parce que le jeune était quand
même chez soi hélas elles ne sont pas
chez elle malgré donc que ça il ya quand
même quelque chose qui ne faut pas
minimiser j'allais dire c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est important et et
des personnes à l'inversé personnes
âgées accueillent quelqu'un chez elle
donc effectivement c'est pour ça que
j'ai entendu quelques fois ça ne peut
pas être défi tard par exemple parce que
on a parlé d or ou des problèmes peuvent
être voilà donc ok ok arbitres prennent
personnes on n'invite pas plein de
personnes chez quelqu'un de l'âge et au
départ on n'est pas non plus chez soi et
donc c'est voilà c'est des contraintes
aussi c'est aussi des limites je pense
que c'est un moment important dans une
trajectoire et qui peut rendre service
aux deux c'est intéressant aussi ce qui
était dans le reportage des personnes
qui gardent des liens après parce que ça
veut dire voilà que c'était un moment
positif et dont elles vont garder
quelque chose mais ça reste un moment
c'est ça il n'y a pas de solution
miracle il n'y a pas de solution idéale
il faut que ce soit un choix des deux
côtés oui oui tout à fait il faut que ce
soit vraiment un choix effectivement
comme disait madame bresson ça ça ne
peut pas correspondre forcément à toute
la population à tous les jeunes et à
tous les seniors puisque à une vraie
démarche d'accueil l'association propose
trois dispositifs en fait pour répondre
aux besoins différents il ya la
possibilité d'être logé gratuitement
pour un jeune donc ça ça correspond à
des étudiants qui arrivent dans deux
avec de grandes formes de précarité les
parents ne peuvent pas supporter le prix
d'un loyer et puis ces jeunes parfois en
ont fait l'expérience de travailler à
côté pour payer un loyer travailler dans
un supermarché tous les week-ends ou le
soir après les études et bien les
résultats ont été difficiles parce
qu'ils ont dû redoubler une année ou
bien ils sont extrêmement fatigué et c
est la possibilité d'être logé comme ça
sans frais eh bien ça leur offre un
cadre de vie agréable confortable et ils
n'ont pas l'angoissent du travail du
loyer à payer et il se liste donne
complètement à leurs études donc ça
c'est très très très positif pour pour
eux une autre un autre dispositif qui
est des services donc le jeune rangs des
petits services qui sont établis dans le
contrat et à ce moment là il a plus de
lille n'est plus libre entre guillemets
parce que dans la formule gratuite le
jeune doit être présent le soir et la
nuit donc là on s'adresse à une
population généralement plus âgés à oran
dans le grand âge et puis pour la
formule avec des petits services et bien
c'est plutôt des seniors un peu plus
autonome et puis une formule avec un
loyer économique alors ça ça permet
d'aider des seniors qui ont des
retraites faible on a beaucoup de
personnages etc ont du mal aussi à
pouvoir rester chez elles parce qu'il ya
des frais à supporter et c'est vrai que
le complément de loyer de revenus pardon
ça leur permet de pouvoir rester chez
elle alors c'est vrai que tous ces
dispositifs mis en place implique des
règles comme vous le disiez et on peut
pas faire venir des personnes de
l'extérieur effectivement pour les
jeunes c'est pas possible c'est pas le
lieu mais quand nous on les reçoit en
entretien on est on est très clair là
dessus et puis effectivement quand ça ne
correspond pas en les oriente vers une
autre solution
mais c'est vrai que ces règles soient
respectées après une fois que le binôme
fonctionne bien au fil du temps on se
rend compte que il ya des
assouplissements certains seniors disent
ben oui tu peux vite et on a mis à venir
pour travailler et c'est donc il ya
quand même des assouplissements autour
de ça mais mais voilà ça au des
possibilités avec un cadre effectivement
à respecter mais quand chacun y trouve
son compte finalement nous le résultat
est plutôt concluant puisque les
étudiants
renouvelle et puis réussissent leurs
études donc ça c'est une vraie
satisfaction pour nous mais aussi pour
les seniors qui les accompagnent oui cet
aspect financier on en a parlé pour les
deux parties en 2018 le coût moyen d'un
hébergement en maison de retraite était
de 1850 euros par mois les pensions de
retraite ne les couvrent pas souvent
maryse bresson ça permet aussi de
retarder la perte d'autonomie la
personne seniors se retrouvent à
continuer à faire des activités qui ne
fréquentait plus en maison de retraite
avec des gens de leur âge qui ne sont
plus assez autonomes
alors la question de l'autonomie elle
est cruciale des deux côtés et à
l'autonomie physx quelquefois voilà voir
voir cognitives mais bon pour les
personnes âgées et puis l autonomie
aussi pour les jeunes qui cherchent
également à s'autonomiser sur le marché
de l'emploi mais moi je pense sont
partis c'est pas moi qui les ai
inventées un donc c'est des auteurs donc
sylvie rouxel barbara ruiz qui ont parlé
d'une interdépendance en fait on est
mais on développe d'autres formes
d'interdépendance et je crois que c'est
quoi la c1 c'est un moyen alors d'être
autonome je sais pas mais d'être
interdépendants de manière satisfaisante
pour les deux parties pendant un moment
de leur trajectoire et est donc du coup
effectivement c'est plus satisfaisant
pour un certain nombre de personnes
âgées de pouvoir rester à domicile
quitte à accueillir des jeunes dans des
conditions encore plus stylia lorsque
bertrand a rappelé des réseaux des
intermédiaires des médiateurs je sais
pas comment il faut les appeler donc on
voit bien effectivement qu'il ya ceux
garantis en tout cas qui semble porter
et là effectivement c'est quelque chose
qui devient possible mais j'insiste sur
le fait que c'est pas des solutions
dans une toute étoile de quelqu'un ou en
tout cas qui posent d'autres questions
et d'autres difficultés et bertron lyon
on est pris par le temps donc je vais
terminer avec vous la particularité
c'est vous serez propriétaire du terrain
vous allez si j'ai bien compris le louer
à l'association est-ce que vous aurez
toujours un regard aussi sur les prix
des loyers en faudra beaucoup parlé de
l'impact financer ce que la commune
restera observatrice et flora de la
surveillance sur ce projet
la commune est propriétaire du terrain
sur un long terme ensuite c'est de
l'échangé les change par rapport au
foncier au bal qui doit être encore
travailler aujourd'hui
on est la boue pour
nous c'est la collectivité et le commun
en quelque sorte on est là pour voir
aménager sur le long terme et permettre
de le changer finalement faire évoluer
les modes de vie le sur elles seront le
long terme et dans les axes qui sont
justement le lien intergénérationnel
on considère à magny les hameaux que
c'est une des priorités à pouvoir faire
tenir tout comme la solidarité comme la
transition écologique sur laquelle on
partage on travaille et puis et
participation des habitants donc
forcément comme sur d'autres actions
dans d'autres domaines que nous avons pu
mener on attache une importance
particulière
à pouvoir suivre sur le long terme ses
projets en restant finalement mettre du
foncier en quelque sorte et ça sera le
cas sur ce dossier je pense que nous
nous arrêtions sur ces mots le temps a
filé toujours très vite sur l'eau cette
société il est bien sûr la terminer ce
magazine je remercie nos téléspectateurs
de nous avoir suivis nos trois invités
de s'être rendus disponibles et bien sûr
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro du statut de société
et d'ici là bien sûr prenez soin de vous
[Musique]
il